allo
alors oui ça me colle c'est ça tu vas
bien ouais et ben joyeux anniversaire
c'était aujourd'hui voilà c'est cool je
me suis à trouver et le dit - vous
connaissez la musique là que j'entendais
à l'intention et comment ça tu m'a
invité non j'ai pas le souvenir d'avoir
été invité à ok tu as créé un événement
facebook et j'étais pas répondu nikos a
fait 59 5 ans que facebook moi j support
donc forcément si tu mets glee sur le
support je suis pas inscrit je ne veux
pas tu réponds bah ouais ok on va demain
voilà et 20 j'ai toujours intelligents
fake fils twitter une saveur via daily
que tiko paddock
vous êtes à peu près une centaine
on va faire un test grandeur nature
combien d'entre vous sont affiliés à au
moins un des sites que j a cité le vélo
je m'adresse à la majorité les sabres à
sion il ya quelques temps de cela ma
petite amie qui est désormais une ex
miss aisne m
quelqu'un de bfg fait parvenir de
fausses informations sûrement accompagné
de photos sorties de leur contexte
par le biais d'un réseau social très bon
certes on n'était pas très attachés ça
faisait que de moi de l'aider en sont
mais elle admet ce qui pour partie
c'est là que je me suis un héros
commande quelqu'un que je connais ni
d'adam ni d'eve me démarquer comme ça
dans ma vie privée dans mon réseau
social et y avoir un tel impact
les personnes mal intentionnées il n'y
en a pas
je me suis donc pas intéressé à la
personnel nos moyens qu'elle avait
utilisé pour la demie le réseau se sert
on comprend bien la problématique faut
partir d'abbas qu'est ce qu'un réseau
social au sens informatique
venir réseau social d'un support
informatif donc permettant aux individus
point un groupe d'individus d'avoir des
interactions sociales et des
interactions sociales régulière on va
faire un test grandeur nature sur des
amis que vous avez sur facebook puis
c'est l'heure des réseaux sociaux
combien on brille régulièrement annoncés
par annecy chief qu'ils pensent envoie à
me mettre en panne des sens un peu vain
d'y réfléchir
l'informatique a bouleversé la donne et
support affiliés à cette technologie
support réseaux sociaux informatiques
ont bouleversé notre façon comique notre
lien aujourd'hui on peut se tenir
informé de l'actuelle prend des
nouvelles de claques juste en tapotant
sur son coeur dire à quelqu'un qu'on
l'ait qu'on affectionne
juste par un dc indiqué
ce faire ajouter supprimer des années
qu'on savons qu'au député à la paume ou
une expression concert ça s'appelle être
commuée c'est d'autant plus vrai que
maintenant nous avons le web 3 est passé
chez soi pour avoir internet nous parle
constamment connaît certes des réseaux
sociaux ont beaucoup amélioré notre
façon des prix fut plus rapide plus
instantané aujourd'hui d'ailleurs quand
on est sur une île de l'arrêt des
contacts avec des proches ont de même
sur sa pérennisation accéder à les
informations sur nos poches sans
forcément aller rechercher d'un fils à
l'actualité qui va nous y est ce qu'un
thème en est à fait dans la joie
magnifique déçoit
mais les réseaux sociaux reste un outil
ou lien social un support pour le
maintenir pendant les embastiller avoir
donné un marteau un ouvrier abl poids
consommer non j'exagère les faits l'idée
n'a donné un marteau un idiot ça rien de
plus qu à l'idiot avec un marteau et
voilà dangereuse
ce que je veux dire c'est ce que tout le
monde sait déjà avoir accès à un service
moyen ne veut pas forcément dire bien
sincèrement et les premières déviance le
premier temps j'ai des réseaux sociaux
c'est nous qui faisons dans notre façon
d outils comment les eaux sociaux mal
utilisé le site de bien manger et bien
je vais vous donner certains exemples et
vous réfléchirez ou même à l'expérience
que vous avez le prime de mots avec les
exemples
premier exemple le rapport à la
virtuelle aujourd'hui à travers ces
supports le lien à l'individu peut être
uniquement virtuelle
on a fait l'exemple je pense que tout le
monde ici à plus de trente années sur
facebook pourtant peu d'entre vous un
seul envoi trempant le toujours virtuel
peut prétendre avoir une vie sociale
tout en restant derrière son exacte sans
rencontrer les mange et soeurs pour vous
la définition d'un support serveur
réseau social faire que l'air lui-même
6h de la société autre exemple le
rapport à la vie aujourd'hui ça n'a
jamais été aussi facile de se faire
bizarre
la plupart des réseaux sociaux
fonctionnent pas suggestion
d'affiliation ce qui veut dire que l'ami
d'un ami
le hainaut parfois on ajoute ces
personnes dans notre cercle privé mais
on ne connaît pas vraiment leur
attention ce qu'ils ont fait ce qu'ils
veulent on s'est parfois même pas si la
photo de profil correspond à leur
identité réelle
et pourtant on leur donne l'accès aux
informations qu on veut partager
uniquement avec vous
troisième exemple la perte et julien
sociale à travers solide sur sur ces
supports de plus en plus urgent que de
plus en plus loeb lui mme va vouloir
existe mon trépied
on assiste à des déviances dans les
comportements en exemple les self ans
serveuse ou d'événements comme tu penses
j'ai pensé de ce jour alors si quelqu'un
dans la pièce de m'expliquer en quoi ce
que mon ami a mangé la veille et une
interaction sociale qualitative
intéressant pour le disent parce que moi
j'ai pas encore plus demandé autour de
moi personne ne veut d'un imanol
nouvelle façon d'utiliser les réseaux
sociaux principale il ya un danger aussi
mais celui là est bien juré sur social
on lime
derrière les grandes sociétés comme
facebook ou twitter
qu'est-ce que des multinationales
américaines
leur but c'est quoi cette sphère du
compte on peut pas aller avant leur
anglais mais c'est leur fonction
première
sur la partie
sauf que le bol vis et on est traqué ne
donnait sont rendus on va déterminer
notre périodicité d'achat sont elles
sont même pas afin de nous rendre sa
roue groupe de communication on va faire
un test
dans nature qui d'entre vous a déjà reçu
passe par une publicité intempestive sur
un article qui la lui mentionnait déjà
d'une conversation ou qu'il est parti
voir deux jours aujourd'hui vers l'avant
c'est vrai elle est connue de ces bons
réseaux sociaux et il va falloir s'y
habituer
ça fait 10 ans que sa soeur eu de chance
il y à peu près 80 secondes lors du boom
des réseaux sociaux j'avais deux jours
soit subit elle aussi stable
ma fille est alors entre eux vu que tous
mes amis étaient déjà sans faire de la
résistance
c'est ce que j'ai fait
ensuite il ya un an avec un groupe
d'amis je me suis dit pourquoi pas
donner notre vision du réseau social
là vous avez en vous là la définition
d'un d'un réseau social
à quoi ça sert les grandes sociétés type
réseaux sociaux aujourd'hui ne tente
plus à assumer leur fonction première de
réseau social ce ne sont plus des
supports qui permettent aux individus
d'avoir vos interactions sociales
régulière mais des supports collecte de
données massives l'alternative des
réseaux sociaux plus loin un réseau
social plus et type permettant vraiment
la rencontre entre les personnes
partir de l'idée début de base en
organisant des fonctionnalités sans
permettre d'être à bel air où son combat
et vend les infections
ça a été notre jeu et on a fait une
proposition bon s'appelle i might be
il va exercer une application réseau
social géolocalisé
vous pouvez laisser un message on greffe
sur un domaine de proximité pourquoi
pour permettre la rampe
ray entre individus entre personnes
ramener le réseau social à l'échelle
humaine
c'est ça l'idée permettre aux gens de se
rencontrer de voir qui on a en face aux
autres pour ensuite maintenir un lien
social sur un support sur une zone plus
large
ina fr permet également aux personnes de
rejoindre d'espère d'intérêt l'open
rassembler les gens autour d'intérêts
communs de conviction créer ce père de
proximité rencontrer les gens voient
fermer l'un des valeurs sont celles de
la soldate de l'entrée connaître ceux
qui sont autant de mieux s'intégrer à
son environnement social culturel voir
les concerts à londres
pourquoi pas ce soir commercial pour les
blancs qui sont poreuses et modèles
économiques ollie traquer les jambes de
revendre des données parce qu'on aurait
pu faire sur une espionne nazie
nous notre objectif c'est vraiment des
trainings au lien social le conseil pour
respecter la vie privée des personnes
n'a brisé un label qui signifie que les
deux et nous amassons sont cryptées pour
directement supprimés récemment mais
c'était tout à l'heure on gagne de
l'argent par la publicité mais n'est pas
la publicité investir sur l'émail ce
faire vous avez sélectionné par un
système de filtres évolutif vos centres
d'intérêts le soir la ville
et vous allez recevoir de la pupille
manquons vous serez à proximité d'un
magasin proposant ce types d'armes avec
l'europe en dessous ça permet aux gens
d'avoir que les informations qui les
intéressent vous voulez pas recevoir de
notification c'est simple vous
désactivez les films que vous utilisez
que les fonctions sociales revenir un
véritable lien social
parce que le lien social cees nooteboom
entre indique en discutant si on
s'imagine la commune étant à l'aise sur
les réseaux sociaux actuels
on peut s'imaginer un monde où on
échangeait tous de la même façon on se
dirait tout ce qu'on s'applique cieux de
la même façon nous change de nos photos
dialoguer tous de la même façon au
travers d'un âne support c'est ce que
visent les bambous actuelle avoir un
support standard mondial pour récolter
le plus de données possibles
ils ont presque réussi regardez
aujourd'hui vous allez sur un site de
rencontre à notre
notre site lien social on va vous
proposer de vous inscrire via facebook
parce que on parle du principe que tout
le monde en rêve
on aura aussi devenu automatique si vous
êtes célibataire ce que recherchait je
suis servir gucci j'ai proposé ma vision
binaire sociale outre la pythie j'ai
fait une pause je vous invite tous à
réfléchir sur la façon qu'on a
aujourd'hui comique notre rapport
retrouvez l'essentiel ce qui est
important qu et si nécessaire de
rectifier
merci
nous